[Música]
a
en mexico la máxima autoridad en materia
de cifras es el instituto nacional de
estadística y geografía inegi y esta
instancia ha dicho que no será sino
hasta octubre de 2021 cuando dé a
conocer la lista de las principales
causas de muerte de los mexicanos
durante 2020 sin embargo y de manera
excepcional hizo un corte de caja en
agosto pasado y de los 108 mil 657
muertos por kobe 19 que hubo en los ocho
primeros meses de ese año concluyó que
sería la segunda causa de muerte por
abajo de las enfermedades del corazón y
por encima de la diabetes mellitus no
obstante y ya con datos de la secretaría
de salud el 31 de diciembre de 2020 que
arroja un total de 125 mil 807 muertos
por coronavirus investigadores de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
en conjunto con colegas de la
universidad de washington y la fundación
carlos slim hicieron un estudio que les
permite estimar que en realidad el
coming 19 habría sido la principal causa
de muerte de los mexicanos en 2020
acotaron sin embargo que habría que
esperar al dato oficial del inei y que
en octubre próximo
[Música]
en 2020 costa rica tuvo un aumento del
7% en el número de muertes respecto a la
cantidad registrada del año anterior con
más de 26.000 muertes en un país de 5
millones de habitantes es el dato más
alto de los últimos 5 años
lakovic 19 fue la principal causa de
muerte en el país desplazando a los
infartos y una de las causas del aumento
de la tasa de mortalidad hasta 5.1 por
cada 1.000 habitantes según el instituto
nacional de estadística y censos el
coronavirus provocó el 9 por ciento de
las muertes de 2020 es decir 2300 de un
total de 26.000 defunciones hasta el 31
de diciembre del año pasado el 70 por
ciento de las muertes relacionadas a la
cob y 19 se dio en personas de más de 35
años
principalmente en hombres
el año pasado se redujeron las muertes
por otras causas como los accidentes o
la violencia
posiblemente por las medidas de
confinamiento que ordenaron las
autoridades debido a la pandemia
[Música]
el coronavirus fue la principal causa de
muerte en colombia durante el 2020 según
el departamento administrativo nacional
de estadística dañe del total de 266 mil
800 muertes que se produjeron en la
nación a lo largo del año 50 mil 71
fueron confirmadas por el virus además
otras trece mil 290 muertes se
consideran como sospechosas de haberse
producido por esta enfermedad en total
una de cada cinco muertes producidas en
este periodo se debe a decesos
confirmados o sospechosos por kobe 19
esta dolencia tuvo también un impacto
mucho mayor en hombres que en mujeres ya
que un 64,2 por ciento de las víctimas
fueron de género masculino mientras que
las mujeres que fallecieron por esta
causa sumaron el 35,8 por ciento en
cuanto a edad casi un 74 por ciento de
las muertes fueron personas mayores de
60 años y casi un tercio del total de
las víctimas fueron mayores de 80 años
de esta enfermedad fue catorce veces
mayor a la del cáncer de mama y de
próstata y diez veces mayor a la del
cáncer de estómago y a la de la
enfermedad pulmonar época